reject nation in honor of thor love and thunder
the newest installment in the mcu we are going to
rank the entire mcu now this is favorites this is
my experience not best because art is objective
so we're going to go through this journey but
we are going to include the television shows i
asked greg he said no no film and i was like greg
it's important he's like okay that doesn't make
sense because the events of falcon and the winter
soldier are affecting captain america four because
now it's captain america the winter soldier just
like in the comic books the events of spider-man
affect daredevil affect the annuals
affect the big events like secret wars
so too to the shows build up to the movies it's
all one shared universe so we're gonna rank
everything all 36 properties we're gonna be
going through the whole thing and if you enjoy
this please do leave a comment let me know what
yours are as well and as always like subscribe
hit that notification bell do all the things on
youtube that i always forget to say and greg's
like yeah that's the thing follow me on tick tock
i'm gonna do a lot of these i'm gonna do a lot of
rankings i give you lots of comic book news movie
news all sorts of things over my tick tock 15 one
minute three minutes all sorts of links i love
tik tok i love you guys more let's get into it
at number 36 surprising absolutely no one and if
you know me you know i defend this movie i'm not
saying the movie's bad but something had to end
up at the bottom thor the dark world now i think
this is a movie that really struggles with tone
changes and experiencing one linear story i think
a big problem with this film is that loki was
so good in avengers they added that whole plot
which cost us a lot of interesting details with
malik i think malikith has a lot of potential as
a dark health to be a very interesting villain but
when you combine that with trying to build out the
asgardian myth building out alan taylor's version
of this medieval world we built into i think it
did cost us a lot of very interesting storyline
that combined with the natalie portman jane foster
having various degrees of chemistry plus balancing
a lot of comedy with kat dennings and the comedy
of thor while thor's evolving from his fish out
of water into this warrior which then changes
entirely i think it's a very difficult film in
the entirety of the mcu this film does however
benefit from some later on changes retroactively
making a lot of the family elements so important
it's an important film but something had to
end up last in my opinion for the dark world
number 35 and i am so sorry i wanted to
love this a lot more than i actually did
this movie made a billion dollars so i am
probably in the minority here it is captain marvel
this movie to me was one of the experiences where
i was a little worried about the shape of the mcu
it did a lot of things where it felt like it
didn't necessarily trust the audience there were a
lot of moments where there's her rising up through
montages over and over again and i was like yes
i love this empowerment story i love what we're
going for but that's not you don't have to tell
me again i understand and i feel like it didn't
trust the audience it also felt like two different
versions of a story i love these directors
mississippi grind is incredible and it's kind
of a funny story is one of my favorite dramedies
it didn't land for the mcu it's also one of the
first times the film looked cheap it looked like
it telegraphed the twist that didn't feel like a
twist and we were supposed to feel like it was
a twist it does however have one of my all-time
favorite stan lee cameos it also features some
very beautiful dragon ball zs action and i really
like brie larson as captain marvel i want captain
marvel 2 to be all the things i wanted captain
marvel 1 to be and i think now that we've met her
we'll have that opportunity highest hopes for nia
costa to take over to be honest all right coming
in at 34 and hopefully showing it's not a recency
bias this is a phase 4 experience which means it's
more recent and yet it didn't land for me i try
to look at the mcu as a whole this is serialized
almost television there are so many installments
it does affect the whole and we'll talk about
that more as we get into the middle of this
whole run but what if for me landed about 34
i think it was trying to do two things it was
trying to build out the universe with these really
high stakes but unfortunately the flaw of it was
i never felt like there were stakes it was
trying to grow things out cosmically it was
trying to expand the universe but it never felt
like anything that could happen in what if could
affect where we went with the mcu and i think we
really saw that after with doctor strange doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness teased zombie
strange wasn't the same one it teased a undead
wanda but that was oil from ultron on her face it
teased a lot of the things we thought were visual
cues from what if but it kind of undermined
what if by not using those characters there
were moments that absolutely sang i loved the
animation especially in the captain carter episode
i loved iron man cap i really really enjoyed
the story line with t'challa's star-lord and
all of those possibilities but unlike the what if
comics i never felt like those events would matter
and i feel like in the mcu everything needs
to at least matter what if didn't quite land
for me never felt connected week to week didn't
feel like an event series like the others did
coming in at number 33 and now we're into the
comfortable bees i feel like these are all bees
and up unfortunately something had to be at the
bottom of the bees and that is iron man 2. a lot
of the things people don't like about this movie i
actually enjoy it is a bit chaotic it is a lot of
high energy it does feel spontaneous but i think
a lot of that spontaneity though it costs the film
being 32 or higher is fun to revisit i do think
after armor wars this film would be more important
just like end game and infinity war made thor dark
world better by retroactively adding importance i
feel like iron man 2 will do the same at the end
of the day it is still tony stark having a good
old time but it is john favreau hanging out having
a good time with iron man it has maybe my favorite
iron man suit up of the entire cinematic universe
that suitcase suit is very cool visuals but the
lack of weight the lack of overall importance and
the overall rush this came out two years after
iron man 1 makes this about 33 and makes this
the lowest b ranking of the entire mcu for me
all right number 32 another b minus for me is the
first thor this movie i do think is better than a
lot of people give it credit for it is a very fun
build out of both shakespearean and comedy but it
does suffer from having to be a lot of things
at once after iron man and captain america we'd
had more traditional comic films iron man is
groundbreaking in a lot of ways but we'd seen
that type of movie before tony stark and batman
are pretty similar kind of guys captain america
is a war film kind of like the rocketeer these
are familiar elements we're adding a thing that
is different from those elements in this god world
we're adding a literal god of thunder that is a
hard thing to build out of so i give this movie a
lot of wiggle because it does balance the gods it
does balance the visuals of what kenneth branagh
was building with the shakespearean lore and it
does add a lot of comedy think about the scene
where he wants to buy a horse big enough he can
ride or a bird or what have you think about the
another think about all those things and then
think about what they do build out from and i
think it's a lot stronger than people remember
but 31 other things are better number 31 and still
a b minus is incredible hulk the incredible hulk i
do think is slightly better than these other ones
for me including thor i think we were gonna have
a really interesting edward norton hulk but i do
think the studio and edward norton saw the hulk
differently if you hear and i'm not comparing this
movie two things that didn't get made but if you
hear any stories about what hulk was gonna become
in incredible hulk 2 with edward norton wanting
to do this kind of spiritual walk about this
existential movie pondering i think that's where
they wanted to go but that's not exactly a team
movie i think mark ruffalo's hulk is an incredible
team hulk i love mark ruffalo's hulk edward
norton if you're gonna do the solo endeavors if
you're gonna have it feel like the 70s comics
if you're gonna have it feel like the show
i think this is an incredible spiritual sequel
to the hulk show and i think edward norton is
an incredible hulk and i also think it's a really
fun time with the villain i also think the world
building is so important that they brought back
thunderbolt ross and certain characters one of the
strengths of what if was building out this world
i just think this world didn't fold in as neatly
as it needed to for the greater mcu and it gets
cost kind of getting eliminated in the process
and number 30 another recent addition another show
for me hawkeye hawkeye did a lot of right things
by having the aha run and fractions reflected on
screen it did a lot of great things by bringing us
kate bishop it had an incredible bridge sequence
but it did suffer in a lot of the ways that what
if did for me where it kind of built up a lot
of stakes and then undermined them i do enjoy
some of the twists and turns marvel does with
playing with characters i don't necessarily love
how kingpin landed after all that setup kingpin we
saw in the same actor in the same portrayal in the
same universe now technically with daredevil as
that dark r-rated crush a guy's head in the car
door it's very hard when we're immediately
trained from a major character that's been
built up the whole season maybe if he wasn't
built up for six episodes it would have felt
differently but since we had all that build up
it did undermine things this is as high as it is
because the chemistry with kate bishop and jeremy
renner's hawkeye is incredible i did enjoy a lot
of the action and choreography with ronin i did
think having the bros as much as we did was the
right move imagine if the ending was hammerheaded
he was the cartoonish version we got of kingpin
how much better the show would have landed and
that put it at this 30 spot and my number 29 is
the first ant-man i am one of the folks that do
enjoy ant-man and the wasp a little bit more than
ant-man the first ant-man gave us a captivating
scott lang and introduced us to a very fun michael
douglas tank on hank pym but it did suffer for
me from a phase one villain problem and it was
a little too deep in the mcu to let that just go
i love cory stole the actor i never really felt
all too threatened by yellowjacket and i did feel
like it was doing the thing they did in phase one
where it's like what if the villain chose this
turn instead but not landing it a lot of the fun
of these villains is that they're mirrors of their
character a lot of the fun of these characters is
that you understand where both the villain and
the hero are coming from i do unfortunately felt
like the limited screen time the overall plot
of the technology and all of those things they
were building to and the corporate espionage led
corey stoll to give us in the editing room maybe
not even on the day a little bit too mustache
twirling and the mustache twirling made this film
feel like it was just an okay side mission and
ant-man's a hard enough character to land so the
paul rudd charm and all those things make it where
it does but the villain puts this in the lower
range of the beast and the next one up 28 ant-man
and the wasp to me this is improvement over the
first because the villains work a lot better for
me we have even less screen time with ghosts but i
was invested in ghost i cared about her journey
i was very invested in lawrence fishburne as
goliath i was super interested in the dynamic
between ant-man and the wasp more this time
because in the first film i felt like they kept
saying like i'm the one that trained for this i
could do great at this and then they're like but
we're not gonna let her like there was like three
sets of jokes about the wasp being more prepared
and not doing it and then in this movie they're
like oh we should probably let the wasp be the
wasp so that's already an improvement over the
first one for me i thought the fight choreography
is so great in this i thought the use of the fun
visual aesthetic a la honey i shrunk the kid with
the giant hello kitty exploding the use of the car
david the small tune got more to do and more to
play with here the supporting cast felt like they
had already formed the team that's so important
in that fun run in the comics the team felt like
they were as important as ant-man and to me when
you've got an ensemble cast like this that's
essential so you add an ensemble cast the charm of
paul rudd the greatness of the wasp and villains
that actually work i do think ant-man the wasp
is a solid b and above his predecessor another
solid b and my 27th pick this one's interesting
this one's very recent is doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and i think this movie is
largely subjective of your experience of the style
of filmmaking on one hand it's been really tricky
phase one through three where you've had to live
in between these walls of the sandbox following in
the mcu and making sure your artistic style kind
of ebbed and flowed but if you look at what james
gunn did with guardian he was able to make it his
while also working in the cosmic parameters of
marvel i do think this is very much an incredible
sam raimi film it is a solid b for me because
sam raimi got to flex his creative muscles that
he uses so well and he got to tell an incredibly
captivating story unfortunately that incredibly
captivating visually very apparently lush story
that stylistically sang sacrificed for me scarlet
witch who had been on a journey with for so many
so many years we'd seen one through six of her ten
moment arc and then it felt like we went to nine
and ten i needed to see seven and eight i got to
enjoy one through six and then nine and ten but
she literally did a heel turn visually into a
color palette and it felt like it sacrificed too
much for this to be higher while enjoying the film
i think that didn't work within the mcu if
this was a what if and they made the what if
an anthology series it might be in my top 15
mark number 26 and probably a lot lower than
other people putting this on their list maybe
one of my most controversial age of ultron
avengers age of ultron is a lot like dark world
in that it retroactively has solved a lot of
problems but it's like five movies at once and
unlike avengers one and infinity war end game
it feels like it it suffers a bit from a mix of
tonalities there are so many moments that were
vision wielding mjolnir them all talking in the
barn the scene with thor and hawkeye's family
is one of my favorite all-time mcu scenes but
unfortunately a lot of those moments feel like
a series scattering of things and ultron didn't
really feel like he had an age it was like the
moment of ultron and i understand why they had to
do that and i understand what the ultron character
was trying to represent and i love the concept of
ai and these overwhelming odds and what it means
to be self-aware and i love the headier concepts
but because it was already juggling so many things
and because it killed the fastest man alive i get
he was sacrificing if rocket was a great moment
it didn't feel like the characters all got their
time to shine in the right way it all felt like
they were trying to share it felt like they were
all in a play and everyone wanted the last line
and no one could have the last line and
that went on for far too long to make this
any higher for me number 25 another very
strong solid b for me is doctor strange one
i rewatched this recently and it actually went up
a few numbers in my ranking because i realized the
visuals and the world building and everything
that we had to accomplish with the mythology is
so dense and so much and also really looking at
it compared to what i think they've been doing
with phase four i was really impressed that it was
so different unfortunately and this is no one that
actually worked on the film's fault tony stark and
dr steven strange have very similar origins and
a lot of times i found myself even on re-watches
wanting to watch iron man especially because the
villain in this casilius never felt like it was
doing a lot for me in the film i dug the ancient
one i dug wong i dove the entire world of doctor
strange but without the villain really working
i kept wanting to go back to the the cloak of
levitation i just felt more drawn to than this and
i love the inceptionist visuals and i love that
the mythology felt real i feel like i could pick
up a book from within this world and learn about
it because scott derrickson built such a lush
world but i also feel like because the villain
wasn't higher i couldn't rank this higher than
25 as much as i loved or mamu i think if you took
out cassellius just had the dormammo story and his
training it'd be in my top 15. number 24 and one
of the first marvel films to make me cry guardians
of the galaxy 2. this film is just chock full of
daddy issues and they all really landed because
you were already so emotionally invested in these
characters that's how you do a sequel you build up
the emotional investment in the first and then
you tell an insane larger than larger than life
story in the second i never thought we'd see ego
the living planet in the mcu now that seems almost
normal after the events of dark world and all
the things we've had but this time five years
ago 2017 that is just such an abstract concept and
as played by kurt russell there are so many scenes
that are the most absurd thing spelling them out
and they work so well in this film the reason this
film is so high up for me is because it grabs the
absurd it grabs the visuals of james gunn it adds
the irreverent humor of james gunn and it puts
it all in a box that feels like it is both in
the mcu like the most guardians of the galaxy from
the obscure comics of the 70s thing i could ever
imagine it is the perfect amalgamation of tones if
you're into this world while not being as good as
the first one but still building out the universe
i think this film really works in a lot of ways
i just don't find myself re-watching it as often
and that's why it's so low 23 here we are with
black widow this is a film that i think if it
had come out in phase two or phase three would
also be higher and i think me personally reading
comic books continuity's a real question mark like
i can accept watching a black widow movie after
she already died maybe more than people that are
just in the film and tv versions of marvel like
it didn't bother me nearly that much what did
bother me is that i was so so in for the jason
bourne tone i was so in florence pew getting her
time to shine and and do that soft reboot so we
get her as a black widow i was so in for david
harbor i was so in for the action set pieces but
i didn't love that we got all of the brutality in
some scenes and didn't get the brutality
of taskmaster and others i love the idea
of taskmaster being from her past like she was i
love the idea of the taskmaster twist i i think
her being a female villain is interesting because
she wouldn't have to be you know physically a
certain way especially in that kind of suit
but making it robotic removing the power set
of taskmaster studying undermines a very important
character the greater mcu and this villain kind of
messed up the comic continuity in a way that
i couldn't really let this movie be higher
even though my experience of watching the movie
and the other nine tenths of the movie was
something i really really enjoyed this is a strong
b plus for me personally another b plus is captain
america the first avenger this one lands right
here because it builds out a very interesting
world this was so early in the mcu and it's still
so interesting you get the red skull on screen as
hugo weaving which is so captivating but i do feel
there are some moments of i don't feel the menace
of the red skull and that's one of the reasons i'm
excited for dr doom is i feel like where marvel
didn't know what to do with overarching villains
they did do great work with bringing back an
infinity war but i did feel like the red skull of
the comics is so ominous and i felt some of that
in the movie but i loved the character design
i loved the vehicle and weapon design i love
the entire world built this over extreme rocketeer
world and the relationship with bucky and steve is
incredible the transformation of steve rogers from
that skinny steve to the steve we need to this day
holds up visually the things they're able to do
with visual effects practical effects and cgi
combined together i know two of those redundant
but putting that all together into one beautiful
thing this movie holds up so well and i think the
strength of this movie is a huge part that the mcu
has done as well as it have because we trust and
we need captain america another solid b-plus and
this one's interesting because it's kind of a
twist if you guys have noticed i've really had
faults with the villains that have knocked the
movie down for me because i think a movie is only
as good as its villain a lot of things can work
but if the villain doesn't that personally affects
my experience of the film this one is interesting
because to me spider-man is about new york and
spider-man hasn't been in new york much especially
in far from home spider-man far from home
we'd been to space we'd touched on new york but
then we went to europe and a lot of that didn't
really work for me i really wanted some small town
spider-man we'll get to the most recent spider-man
because of its improvements as we go along but a
lot of the comedy didn't quite land with some of
the relationshipy stuff but overall it is a very
very pleasant experience some of the best visuals
i have ever seen for spider-man hard stop and
the best villain i could imagine for a spider-man
sequel i think jake schillenhall's mysterio is
one of the few prophetic villains in the mcu
we're gonna see more and more drone culture we're
gonna see more and more deep fakes we're gonna see
more and more that we won't yet understand if it's
real or not mysterio played on a character written
in the 60s modernized it made it prophetic and
managed to incorporate it into the greater mcu
that is the best magic trick you can pull in the
mcu you make it a seed you've already planted you
make it something that's going to be even more
relevant in the future you cast jake gyllenhaal
getting to do his most theater kid performance
like he i i it's the combination of donnie darko
jake gyllenhaal day after tomorrow jake gyllenhaal
and nightcrawler jake gyllenhaal one character
and you put that in a cgi spectacle with that
incredible remedia sequence i loved mysterio
on this i loved the visuals in this some of the
things didn't work but it's still a very high b
plus for me far from home number 20 is falcon and
the winter soldier i don't know why retroactively
this has become like not as beloved but week
to week this was such a journey this was such
event television and especially there's a
sequence and i believe it's the fifth episode
where u.s agent literally decapitates someone with
his shield and i thought that was a fascinating
commentary on the world today comic books i'm
sorry for any people in this chat that are going
to get mad at me for saying this are political
there's this guy captain america he's punching
nazis in the 40s and still punching nazis today
i thought using a show about falcon becoming
captain america and addressing certain brutality
and addressing certain current events was very
very brave and very important storytelling add
to that you get an actual therapy session all of
phase four is about therapy all these characters
need therapy bucky goes to [__] therapy and it's
required i love that this invested in white uh
white wolf i love this invested in winter soldier
separately i love that this invested in falcon
and in captain america separately this kind of has
four leads and of course their civilian identities
i loved all of the stuff in new orleans i love
that anthony mackie felt like he got to bring his
nest to sam wilson and i especially loved baron
zemo i never thought i'd be as invested in the
daniel bruhl take on berensema after civil war
and now he's up there of my all-time favorite
villains and why i think thunderbolts will work
is because of this show 19 and guaranteed to
get me into hot water with mcu fans is thor
ragnarok you heard me thor ragnarok i know a lot
of people love it and i really enjoy it but to me
it is a lot of leaps in my uh approachability to
the character i think that ragnarok gave us the
best thor we've ever had in infinity war and
endgame because it balanced the drama and the
comedy but while it's just comedy ragnarok is a
lot for me i do think there's a lot of things that
feel like they're done for the joke not for the
story i feel like at points it does feel improv
troopy which doesn't fit the rest of the mcu for
me doesn't necessarily fit the comic book for me
but what it does do it give me spectacular visuals
give me world war hulk build out the universe give
me the best possible jeff goldblum this movie
is so insane that jeff goldblum at an 11 doesn't
feel out of place i love thor screaming going
through that tunnel i love thor dealing with a
very cantankerous hulk i love all of these things
but it didn't feel like it was the character i'd
been living with or the character that i know
from the comics again if this was a what if
if this was removed or if this came after i don't
know a different thor three that gave us a little
more comment it just it felt like a lot to go
from two to this three a lot worked grand master
the villain hella is on my rushmore of villains
what it did for sadness what it did to continue
thor's walkabout journey of figuring out who he
is by removing his very people he's the god of
asgard and they took away most of asgard who are
you as a man without your people if you're a king
it asks a lot of important questions does a lot of
fun things but overall isn't as high as a lot of
people for me number 18 and right above ragnarok
for similar reasons and you've heard me talk about
this a lot recently is thor love and thunder you
know i have some issues with some of the tonality
i do enjoy the second half the film quite a bit i
do have some problems with the first half of the
film but some of the things i especially enjoyed
were the family aspects i really enjoyed the way
this movie lands i do think the last five minutes
are amongst my favorite five minutes at the end of
any mcu film post credits were absolutely that
phase one post-credit glory but the movie itself
did feel like it was figuring itself out as it
went along i feel like we got a very different
movie that landed in theaters than the four hour
assembly cut which we don't need to see it's not
the snyder cut the thing that went into the edit i
feel like might have been a very different movie i
could have used some more butchering i could have
used some more jane foster i could have used a lot
more king valkyrie as it stands now it's it's
in the middle of my marvel experience but what
made it so interesting was everything they did
to make me feel for gore i really loved gore i
really think tyke is two for two with villains
i really understood where he was coming from i
really empathized with him and i really liked all
the choices they made visually around him but some
of the comedy didn't work for me so it's about the
middle for marvel higher than people would expect
number 17 is moon knight i know a lot of folks
uh didn't love how this landed and that kind of
colored their entire experience of the film it
did change my experience this had been a little
bit higher i didn't necessarily love episode six
but i did adore episodes one through five i love
the psychology i love the talent of oscar isaac
on display every episode the scene outside the
steak restaurant is some of the best acting in
marvel and i'm not letting that go because it
didn't have the exact end i wanted i also think
if they made the post credit scene actually part
of the show like just tie it in that would have
elevated the whole experience it's weird little
details and choices the cgi on some of the fights
didn't quite work for me i know there's budgetary
constraints i know it's a tv show but those little
things chipped away at it but everything else
worked for me i love that there's a moon night
show that feels like moon night this feels like
lemire smallwood run come to life this feels
like ellis this feels like declan shalvie this
feels like the things i've always loved about
moon knight with the mythology with the world
building with the insane fight club elements and
oscar isaac and ethan hawk acting their eyeballs
out at each other and introducing very obscure
characters i never thought we'd see on screen this
is very high for me because it showed mythology as
well as gods as well as superheroes is absolutely
possible and we got [__] moonlight guy pierce is
the guy from memento and i really think up until
he got that mustache twirly firebreather stuff at
work i'm also one of the folks that really liked
the twist with the mandarin i think it evolved
even more using the one shot i think that stuff
really worked i love the idea of iconography
being perverted into something wrong i like the
idea of us using these symbols of heroes to make
things not as trustworthy i think all that sings
especially in the world of the comic books i think
iron man 3 we're going to look back on in years as
one of the most important comic book films it is
certainly one of the best made and i think one
of the best acted and it's absolutely an a-modest
for me i love iron man 3. number 15 is the tv show
that i would argue changed comic book television
wandavision wandavision started as this beautiful
commentary on tv and comic books themselves it's
both a commentary and comic book characters and
television as a medium and it evolved both i love
the characterization of where they took scarlet
witch from scarlet witch into wanda maximoff
and back i love her dedication to her children
i love that we told this heartbreaking story
of humanity through a witch and a robot i love
their love i love the supporting cast i loved the
mystery every single week everyone was talking for
the entire six and a half day span about what had
just happened on the show because we were wrapped
up in this mystery i love that had philosophical
concepts like the ship of theseus brought to our
attention if everything changes in a person are
they still that person but by way of vision i love
that this was the kat dennings character i always
wanted to see it get some more time to shine
every character in the show work every beat
of action and comedy no not every 90 beats of
action comedy work and it was so close to perfect
the end for me was a slight foil because i had a
fumble because i do feel like it went to punching
and kicking when it had just been so philosophical
but we kind of needed to see where it would
escalate with these characters this show is a
solid a minus for me and i think it's one of the
best experiences i've had week to week with marvel
fans not only do you invest in the beginning
in the practical martial arts of chongqing that
bus scene is some of the best we've seen a fight
being the mcu but by the third act you're in an
entirely new world you're dealing with creatures
we've never seen before you're dealing with
the re-emergence of the guy you thought was the
mannered in a beautiful new creative and funny
way and you're watching them fight a dragon and
it all still feels like it's in the mcu and you
want a shanxi 2 as much as you want him to be in
the avengers that's a very important distinction
for a lot of phase 4 films i wasn't as invested
in the greater mcu or i wasn't as invested in the
solo story this walked both lines and introduced
us to a new hero and did it perfectly love chongqi
all right you know how hotels sometimes don't
have the number 13 on their elevator we're not
going to technically have a number 13 in this
list because miss marvel's not over yet as of
filming this we haven't seen episode six of miss
marvel as of right now miss marvel falls somewhere
after juan division after shanghai but
if it lands if it sticks the landing i
think that might put it around chongqi so i'm not
exactly sure where it lands but i as of right now
consider miss marvel the a that i consider shongxi
and wan division so it's in this range it might
be 13 it might be 16 but it's in this span miss
marvel for me is doing something really really
difficult it's making an audience that's lived in
this world for 14 years appreciate something that
might just be for 14 year olds or 40 year olds
this show appeals to a young audience as well as
the audience that's grown up with this world this
is the first show where someone in the universe
knows about the universe there's an avenger con
in this world with the wrong set of hands without
the gloves they used on this this could be a
disaster self-referential stuff is very hard
to walk she's literally a fan of captain marvel
and cards herself miss marvel it's doing a great
job building out humanity it's doing a great job
building up family stories it's doing a great job
really remastering a character's power set to
work in a different medium which you have to do
sometimes and it's introducing us to a brand
new actress this is her debut performance a
lot of american audiences including myself don't
know most of these actors on screen and we love
them we're so invested in them internet it is
future koi as promised i just finished the miss
marvel finale and it did stick the landing i had
said i hoped it would land somewhere in that 13
to 16 range and it has that is a beautiful a
range this to me is before moon night and just
after iron man 3. iron man 3 begins my my god tier
this is right there in that beautiful sweet spot
it stuck the landing it introduced lots of new
plot it gave us loving characters it gave us so
much emotion while also building out the world
while also giving us some very interesting power
sets and it gave us a cameo from greg alba it is
about 16 for me i'd say what do you think greg
16. don't don't not not you no it's too big
top 12 or into the solid a range these are
films that would be between a 93 and a 96 if we're
grading it like american school system and my most
controversial take this is for greg these comments
they're for you greg the seo you ready eternals
eternals is number 12. i love this movie because
it did what in my opinion no team comic movie had
been able to do without prior team movies none
of these characters were known to anyone except
the most die-hard comic fan it introduced 12
characters effectively because i'm gonna count
the black knight i'm gonna count some of the
sporting casts that are so important to this
it introduced all of them and they were so well
characterized that even when they were off screen
i knew how they would in their essence
as a character be affected by the events
and it didn't have to be redundant it didn't
have to re-spell things and it did all that while
subverting expectations by having the villains be
effectively what we would be perceived as those
humanoid things as they evolved had sentience
had intelligence and in many ways the eternals
who we just met who we just invested in are
the villains the way this lands is they threw
off billions of lives potential to exist while
saving us as earthlings we were cannon fodder
and yet billions of lives were sacrificed by these
hero villains because they're both in a way and
they're above us and it established a hierarchy
of gods and it gave us so many very very powerful
visuals and moments that grew out the mcu and it
really showed much like iron man 3 the different
type of movie an mcu film can be this film is an
art house film about what it means to be human
by way of what it means to be an eternal and
i cannot wait to see where the ramifications
of the third act of this film go into phase
four and beyond this movie i really think
and hope with time will grow in people's hearts
because it is so special number 11 is a movie i
honestly can say i waited most of my childhood
for it was a movie that gave me a spider-man
that sometimes did heroics for a churro it gave
me a spider-man that felt like at least in the
first 20 minutes had a burrow to take care of and
the reason this one is as high admittedly as it is
because this one's a little tricky is the villain
vulture is one of my rushmore marvel villains in a
couple glances michael keaton is both intimidating
and paternal you understand he's fighting for his
family you understand how it ties into the mcu
just like mysterio i think honestly the spider-man
films as a trilogy are the greatest tie into the
mcu which is ironic because they're a sony marvel
collaboration but they invest you in the past
while moving you forward in the future he's a guy
that's cleaning up it's a different take on damage
control that i think they've had to remaster a bit
because they're going to do a show but it makes
you invest in the fallout of superheroic elements
that's something that is huge in the comics is not
addressed enough in the movies those fallouts are
things that made him a vulture he was a scavenger
of tech and he became a villain and he cared about
his daughters that invested in both peter parker
and spider-man that's the thing about spider-man
what makes spider-man unique is you're as invested
as peter as you and as you are in spider-man and
that's what the vulture brought and tom holland
is the pitch perfect cinematic spider-man i argue
andrew garfield is a comic book adaptation come to
life and toby mcguire is exactly the one we needed
in the 2000s the best mcu spider-man just like
ruffalo is the best mcu hulk is tom holland and
he really got to debut very strong here the moment
you met him in civil war you wanted this movie and
then this movie delivered and it's honestly one
of the most impressive and authentic high school
casts i've seen they feel real they feel grounded
and that allows the elevation of spider-man love
this movie number 10 we're into the top ten these
are all comfortable a bordering on a pluses i got
black panther as my number 10. i love this movie i
love what it did to the world of marvel the people
that love this movie aren't just marvel fans the
people that celebrate this movie are everyone
from rappers i love to grandparents and killmonger
again the theme of villains here is someone that
has a lot of just american ideals there's a lot of
just like that guy makes sense to a lot of people
and what's beautiful is black panther learns
from killmonger killmonger says we need to share
this we need to explore bringing this out to other
people and black panther actually ends up agreeing
with him the way this movie ends is the hero
learning from the villain killmonger makes a lot
of sense in a lot of ways and not in the thanos
was right way in a practical sense so yes in a lot
of ways you need to keep wakanda protected and a
lot of ways you need to share the world what your
gifts are so it's a beautiful story in a hundred
ways there's a lot of beautiful metaphors about
the underground railroad that are used in the
third act a lot of people have some problems with
the third act and some of the cgi if the story is
as good as the story is it doesn't bother me this
movie is from its sound design to its score to its
soundtrack to its visual effects for the most part
to its cast to its science to its world building
to its supporting cast to every element of this
film to the designs in the embroidery in the black
panther suit this film is damn near perfect and i
think that the world of cinema is better for it
and i think that these stakes on black panther 2
couldn't be higher because how do you follow black
panther this movie changed cinema and it certainly
changed the mcu if number 10 changed cinema number
nine changed television and that you could make
a superhero show that was an existential crisis
that was literally a think piece that felt like
you were reading some of the densest philosophy
man of the dances some from very dense philosophy
from your college professor loki dealt with
what it meant to be a human by dealing with
what it meant to be outside of time and be a
god thor is fascinating because it's a story of
humanity by way of a god loki is arguably more
fascinating because he's someone that wants to
belong that's also a god of mischief that feels
like in some ways he's been mislabeled how do you
get your superpowers and then kind of judge what
those imply how do you figure out who you are as
a person if you're inherently deceitful how do
you shape your reality if you don't believe in
a necessary reality add time travel to that that
is beautifully well done add an incredible element
of government regulation that's outside of any
government because it's about time itself in very
fun referential ways add owen wilson as mobius
giving some of the best work of his career some of
the dialogue back and forth between tom hiddleston
nolan wilson is is amongst the best character
scene work you'll see in film or tv and then the
difference between this and for me one division
is episode six where one division was a plus one
through five i did feel like six fell off a bit
loki is a plus one through six it ends with a
shakespearean-esque monologue from our brand
new kang jonathan majors isn't even kang yet he's
the one who remains this shifts everything in the
mcu and it feels important and it feels huge and
we haven't even technically met kang yet because
the writing is so tight so strong cannot wait to
see where kang goes cannot wait to see the world
build out cannot wait for more loki this show
is as close to perfect as i think a show can get
final countdown you lovelies this is eight this
point on any of these people number one depending
on my mood this is one through eight or kind of
a number one shuffle these are tied for first
we're gonna be a pluses i know civil war
doesn't get talked about enough anymore but
if you're gonna follow up winter soldier how
do you do that you make the first at the time
comic book double spread page come to life the
airport fight was the first time in my life i
ever felt like i did that like double fold out and
was like they made a comic book everyone fighting
in that environment feeling exactly like
their characters doing exactly how i'd
wanted those characters see come to life and
the characterization was fascinating you've
got hero vs hero in a way that evolves from the
comics this isn't a translation of the comics
it's an adaptation of the comics making it more
relevant to our world you understand where iron
man's coming from you've fallen in love with that
character you understand where cap is coming from
you've fallen in love with that character and
then your heroes who are perfectly characterized
have to pick sides every punch in this movie lands
twice because you feel the person hitting and
you feel the person getting hit and it introduced
black panther and it introduced baron zemo and it
gave us one of the best translations of spider-man
i think we'll ever see on screen all in one movie
while you're invested in someone who never has to
fire a bullet really baron zemo does all of this
behind doors like emperor palpatine while still
being more charming and impossibly captivating
leading us into phase four and beyond and giving
us some of the best action the mcu has ever had
civil war a plus number seven avengers end
game this movie delivered on an impossible
promise hey we're gonna follow up infinity
war and we're gonna tell the conclusion
to three phases of filmmaking we're gonna conclude
12 years of cinema and we're not going to let you
down we're going to give you the biggest action
you could conceive of we're gonna give you comic
panels come to life and the characters that aren't
their comic counterpart the film sorry they are
the comic counterpart these are the film versions
of the characters we've lived with long enough
that they're doing different things their comic
counterparts might because that's who they are i
love that this movie goes completely different
ways this movie is a beautiful conclusion the
infinity saga but i as a comic book fan didn't
feel like it was color by numbers i got to
experience an entirely new story with characters
i've loved for 30 years and they did it with style
with panache and with consequence the reason this
movie is so high is there are still consequences
to this day the infinity saga has iron man go
from selfish to selfless he sacrifices himself
at the end of end game it has captain america
go from selflesh to selfish and i know that's
in english a bad word it's a swear but sometimes
you need to choose yourself and that's what i
mean by selfish he's finally done fighting he's a
soldier that served his time he's going to peggy
he has chosen to choose himself and then all
through that journey you've got thor finding his
sense of self the big three are all on a journey
of self and this somehow sticks that landing and
brings 20 some odd characters to the fold never do
any of them feel wasted and never do any of them
feel like they're just serving the plot thanos
handled beautifully we'll talk about infinity war
in a second but endgame is a movie that shouldn't
be possible number six i don't know how this
exists this was before we were into the mcu that
deep this movie came out in 2012 we're only four
years into the mcu and they brought five different
franchises together this movie is the avengers
this movie is some of the funniest catchiest most
comic accurate dialogue from these characters
i personally enjoy the dichotomy of doth mother
know you wear with her drapes that thor opposite
iron man so much because he is that shakespearean
character in a lot of continuities and that
dichotomy works so well in this movie captain
america is a guy that's doing more ragtag stuff
as a helicopter hella carrier drops out of the
sky they're all doing what they are as comic book
entities to a level that this allowed us to evolve
into them being their movie versions of themselves
this movie brings comedy brings action brings
vibrant bright colors to this day this is still
my favorite hulk i think whole cook's so good here
and i feel like hulk is so hulk here and you've
got every other element of the movie bringing
this all together shield feels like a real thing
all of these characters feel like they're fully
people you could somehow meet and it's the first
of its kind the imagination and ingenuity of this
cannot be overstated a lot of people that are in
their teens now don't understand how big a deal
this was movies didn't combine with other movies
you didn't go watch keanu reeves in one movie and
he meet john wick keon reeves in another movie we
do that in this movie it's a bad example you don't
combine franchises this movie put different heroes
from different franchises together into one
thing that seemed impossible and they nailed it
this movie is a miracle truly interchangeable
seriously these eight but this one at the top five
are insanely number one uh iron man started all of
this iron man was the biggest gamble maybe in the
the possibilities of the mcu you've got an actor
that wasn't known for this kind of work you've got
john favreau who isn't yet the john favreau that
we trust to just do whatever and they trusted him
to do whatever this is a movie that is so rock and
roll every song is ac dc this is a movie with a
character stanley invented to be unlikable it was
like a challenge to himself he was like i'm gonna
make this guy that's aggressively selfish and is
kind of a warmonger i'm gonna turn into a hero
and they cast a guy that is that and they turned
him into a hero like downey junior stark wouldn't
work if anyone else said those lines the reason
sam rockwell got cast in iron man 2 is because
he went out for iron man 1. tony stark is downey
jr downey jr is tony stark that is a one-of-one
experience and this movie is so effortlessly cool
everything about this movie absolutely rocks and
it was the first so they got away especially with
jeff bridges iron monger it makes sense for the
industrial complex capitalism all the things that
turn someone into that greed is iron monger and it
actually works better for me than in the comics
this character works opposite its villain the
movie works beat by beat the comedy is spectacular
and it gives us the birth of the mcu and
holds up 14 years later with all the advancements
in superhero stuff it's hard to make a movie
that's timeless and iron man absolutely is okay
we talked about in-game being very hard to top
infinity wards because infinity war to me is
number four this is a movie that's around the
villain infinity war is a thanos movie avengers
brought the avengers together and showed us you
can combine genres infinity war showed us hey you
know those people you like we're gonna give you a
villain that yes i'm gonna say it is better than
darth vader we're gonna give you a villain you
identify with that some of you think might
be right and we're gonna make you invest in
someone that's willing to get rid of half the
population there's moments where you're like
that is a rational thought and you're fighting
the people you've loved for so many movies this
does what avengers 1 did exponentially it brings
in infinitely more characters it gives you some of
the greatest fight scenes in history it has that
moment where like thor lands and you're just like
overwhelmed with like how did this even happen i
love the mjolnir cap scene in endgame but i love
even more that this movie gives you so many of
those moments and it doesn't have to feel like a
conclusion end game needed to end everything this
made you like on the edge of your seat i remember
the credits rolled in this film and i couldn't
imagine where things could go and for an entire
year marvel had the balls to make us wait part of
my love of this movie is the experience of that
year where i didn't know what was possible and
then somehow endgame didn't let us down but it's
because of infinity war's launch that i think the
mcu is as strong as it is infinity war a plus i
would change not a single frame so we're gonna get
a tree we're gonna get a raccoon that talks we're
gonna get a character named star-lord and we're
gonna convince you this isn't just a cheap ploy
to sell toys we're also gonna get a director most
of you haven't heard of and we're going to make it
a lot of very very almost r-rated joke and we're
going to keep this all in space and we're going
to do this into phase 2 so it doesn't actually
connect to the characters you care so much about
and we're going to make one of the best comic book
movies of all time guardians of the galaxy one
is insane it's pure madness you care about an
entire team in one movie you care about a team of
miscreant degenerates in one movie you are
so invested in them that when a giant tree
dies you cry with him because we are groot
everything about this movie is emotionally
emotionally manipulative and i say that as
a compliment everything about this movie
pulls at every heartstring you have while giving
you insane cosmic visuals i maintain without
guardians of the galaxy they weren't gonna go
cosmic i think they were gonna let james gunn
make a little side mission with guardians and then
the movie was as good as it was and they were like
let's uh let's see if we can steer the ship and
now we have eternity in the mcu now we're gonna
have the living tribunal and maybe secret wars
all of these things are possible because i think
of the little movie that could one of the braver
choices next to iron man and the entire mcu and
one of the best how does this exist and it stuck
the landing guardians of the galaxy number three
this movie was number one for seven years this was
the movie i didn't think could be dethroned this
is 2015's we're gonna make an espionage thriller
that you your dad your grandpa your grandma your
aunt your cousin your dog walker everyone is
gonna go [__] yeah winter soldier winter
soldier brought back bucky and that is a new to
this time comic book story and made me care about
bucky more than the comic ever had it gave me a
badass villain that is very similar to its hero
again a trope in marvel that this master cap and
winter soldier are so similar they just went off
one path fell off one train in this case and
you're so invested in what this character's
journey is and you love cap and that's without
talking about the action the elevator sequence the
knife fight on the street the stuff they're able
to do with crossbones the way this movie is about
not trusting the systems you've trusted from the
jump this is seven years in the mcu seven years
of like shield are our people they're protectors
they're the organization that keeps us shape we're
gonna assemble a special team we just had the
avengers defend us from cosmic threats the shotari
and now the threats are coming from within how do
you top a space demon coming at you that's the god
of mischievous wielding them you make the threat
inside you make it the systems that you trust not
being trustworthy and you make captain america
go wait a second in his second [__] solo movie
winter shoulder did all of the things exactly
right and gave us to this day in my opinion
the best action in the mcu love winter soldier
it's only topped by one film it finally happened
and this is an interesting thing because i know a
lot of this is my own bias i never thought i'd see
a spider-man on screen that felt like everything
i love about spider-man and i never thought
i would be like wait a six-movie origin story it
took the exact perfect storm of the mcu thriving
and sony rebooting spider-man to allow something
as insane as a six-movie origin story to exist
it lets spider-man become not the spider-man
of the comic books but the spider-man of the
movies and i've always said that tom holland
is the best movie spider-man he represents
all of the things that make spider-man work
cinematically i said a little while ago andrew
garfield to me is comic book spider-man to me
tobey maguire spider-man is foundational to get
the gateway into comic book movies to work he's
a great gateway into what the sam raimi movies
needed to do those are foundational the samurai
movies the x-men movies and blade movies are how
any of this exists but tom holland managed to make
all of that work in this movie by delivering one
of the most gripping performances i i swear if
he was playing a soldier or a cop or anything
that wasn't someone that wore tight he would have
been up for an oscar here if willem dafoe wasn't
wearing a guy that wrote a glider and was just
playing like a crazy busy business magnate he
might have got an oscar nom here the performance
in this are incredible and this is a movie that
uses the best of metamodernism it incorporates
some nostalgia yes but it doesn't weaponize it
it doesn't fan service it it doesn't make you go
that's a reference it uses literally a reference
like the point a meme that shouldn't work twice
and both times it serves the story and both signs
it gives you a moment of levity because how dark
the film is spider-man is a dark character i'm
sorry gwen stacy dies him and mary jane break up
half the time because of mephisto there's lots
of people always hunting him he's always late on
rent he's always chasing a balance of two lives
he's always alone and losing people he's lost
uncle ben he's lost aunt may spider-man's about
loss and in this he lost literally everything
and the opening of this film is him judging
his choices and him being a little selfish by
like oh doctor strange change this change this
and it's that moment of not only spider-man being
quippy and funny not only not realizing because
he's naive which is spider-man but by the end
sacrificing everything because he felt like it was
his fault he has to be the one that says okay i
lose everything that's spider-man with great power
comes great responsibility in this universe we got
to have that delivered by other spider-man we got
to improve on the spider-verse story in the spider
verse one of the greatest films that's not what
i'm saying i'm saying the spider voice story got
to involve the medium of film it got to combine
the medium of film with the medium of comics with
the multiversal impact of a shared mcu with sony
with five spider-man villains this movie made a
sinister six effectively work and you cared about
everyone it used everything we've loved about
superhero movies to build the perfect film it
brought us 20 years of filmmaking to one beautiful
crescendo with comic book accurate visuals
with all the easter eggs you could want but most
importantly the heart of spider-man my number one
mcu film is spider-man no way home and it made
me believe i would have loved it as much at age
eight as i'm gonna love it at 88 and it truly is
revolutionary and it's a near-religious experience
for me there's nothing that makes me feel the
way no hail makes me feel spiderman has meant
the world to me since i was a kid because i've
always felt like liking comics put you over here
and the irony of spider-man being so popular and
bringing you in like people are sharing comic book
love now but it didn't used to be that way and
and because of these movies people share that
so the beautiful irony of spider-man making a
billion dollars and bringing people together
from the pandemic i didn't even include in my
review because that's not the movie it's just
life happened to give me the gift of bringing the
world back together to celebrate spider-man after
spider-man was the thing that made me feel like i
was part of the world and comic books used to make
me feel like i wasn't welcome and now they make me
feel the most welcome because i get to share this
with you guys so this franchise means the world
to me spider-man means the world to me i accept
my bias i know you're going to get uppity i know
you're going to be like that movie just came out
no way home's overrated and they use nostalgia i
don't give a [__] it affected me to a level that
i can't describe and i only hope that you ever
dear audience feel the way i feel about that movie
about anything in your life so uh thank you for
watching this whole i assume very long video thank
you for giving a single about my opinion of movies
i've invested my life into the comic books that
inspired these movies and these movies have given
me almost 15 years of joy happiness and belief
that these dreams can come true so this video is
a culmination of all of that and this video is me
sharing with you my own personal opinions i would
honestly love to hear yours please leave a comment
i'm going to read them up until they get angry
i'm going to read them up until they get toxic
it's inevitable because opinions are personal this
was personal to me thank you to reject nation for
being so supportive i hope you continue to
be enjoy this list let me know you think in
the comments below like subscribe hit that bell
we're gonna be doing lots more videos if you guys
like this list and you watch this whole [__]
thing let me know that as well because there's
a lot more lists we can do and i love ranking
stuff and it's not about what's best it's about
your experience with art and that's all we can
up for in life is to experience art much love